[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Sulaiman Balogun,
co-founder at ToLet.com.ng.
ToLet.com.ng is Nigeria's
busiest online real estate
platform.
We have, since inception,
been able to come up
with a three-part system.
Find a house in
three easy steps.
Look on our website,
see the property
that you're interested
in, and then we attach you
to one of our offline
agents, who would then
help you find-- who
would then basically
walk you through the process
of getting the house.
What we did was
to basically have
absolutely no human
interaction with users.
We had started a classifieds
website at the time.
And what we did, we
basically did not
interface with the
users that much.
However, just from our
contact page alone,
we then started getting emails.
We were inundated
with emails basically
requesting for certain changes
to be made to our website,
and asking for different
types of services which
we didn't provide at the time.
What we decided to do
after that was to set up
our customer service center.
We put up our phone
numbers on the website,
beside the Book
an Inspection tab.
And what we found was
an uptick in the amount
of people that were
actually reaching out to us.
Within the space of
about one week, we
saw like a 200% increase
in the number of users
who were actually contacting us
and asking to view properties
that they had seen
on the website.
There is always a
market for someone
to come and solve that problem.
And we did the maths, we talked
around with our pilot team.
The pilot testers
had already gone out.
We had gotten feedback.
We had looked at
our business model.
We had spoken to
partner agencies.
Everything basically-- we
made sure everything added up.
And even though,
for the most part,
a lot of people on
the outside thought
we were making a big mistake,
we knew from our research
that we were actually
doing the right thing.
And that was probably
the best thing
that happened to our business.
Because at the
end of the day, we
were basically trying to
listen to our customers.
Our customers were giving
us feedback, telling us
what they wanted us to do.
And we knew that so long as
we kept the customer happy,
business was going to be good.
We now find out that 90% of
the users of the ToLet.com.ng
service actually come to
us via the phone calls.
They still use the website.
They use the website.
Nonetheless, they still prefer
to actually call and speak
to a member of a
customer service team,
ask questions, and
get clarifications
before they then go
on to actually decide
to go view the property.
Anybody out there who is
thinking about launching
a new product or
launching a new feature,
so long as that feature that
you are adding to your business
is very key and
crucial to your user,
I can personally assure you
that you should-- I mean, go out
there and launch that feature.
So long as your customer
is asking you for it,
then they will be
willing to use it.
And it could probably
be the biggest thing
that will change the
face of your business
from a very, very small
company to a very, very
huge powerhouse.
[MUSIC PLAYING]